The last question we're going to talk about today came from Elise.
And Elise got really excited by the discussion that Wes was having
with the CTO of Mozilla.
She wants to know how do you create a programming language?
What goes into it?
Well, the good news is that's what we're doing in this course.
We just happen to be creating all the materials needed
to interpret and run programming language that exists,
and that is JavaScript, and interpret html,
which is just how to display something.
But that's how you build a programming language--
exactly what we're doing in this course.
The only difference is that you would change the syntax
and all the features to how you would want it in a language of your choosing.
But this is the course, and I hope by the end
you'll get a very clear picture of what would go into doing such a thing.
All right, well, thank you for your answers, Peter.
And thank you all for your questions.
Thank you, as well. And thank you for being here, Andy.
Thanks to everyone. >>Everyone gets thanks.
See you next week.